es una ciudad que ha quedado
irreconocible por la guerra
sus calles desiertas siguen llenas del
sonido de los constantes bombardeos
a pesar del alto al fuego en el centro
de la ciudad protegido por sacos de
arena este edificio es apodado por los
ucranianos como punto de invencibilidad
en esta gran sala la gente viene a
buscar calor y protección y aquí fue
donde se enteraron de La tregua navideña
de 36 horas anunciada por Vladimir Putin
No creo una palabra de lo que dicen los
rusos y lo que prometió Putin nadie en
Ucrania lo hace puedes escucharlo Hoy
hay disparos sin parar y explosiones
en otra zona de la ciudad una treintena
de personas hace fila para recoger leña
y lograr calentar sus casas en medio del
Fuerte invierno eso residentes de bakmut
se han acostumbrado a los sonidos de los
bombardeos
no he oído nada sobre un alto al fuego
pero cada vez que los rusos anuncian
algo no salen con nada Creo que la
guerra durará
como sobrellevas la situación
[Risas]
estoy aquí porque encontré trabajo Eso
es todo
el presidente ha condenado el alto al
fuego ordenado por Vladimir Putin dice
que Rusia quiere usarlo como una fachada
para